- [Tutor] What I wanna do in
this video is give a primer,
I'm thinking about when to use
a z statistic versus a t statistic,
when we are doing significance tests.
So there's two major scenarios
that we will see in an
introductory statistics class,
one is when we are
dealing with proportions,
so I'll write that on the
left side right over here
and the other is when we
are dealing with means.
In the proportion case,
when we are doing our significance test,
we will set up some null hypothesis,
that usually deals with
the population proportion,
we might say it is equal to some value,
let's just call that P sub one
and then maybe you have
an alternative hypothesis,
that, well, no, the population proportion
is greater than that or less than that
or it's just not equal to that,
so let me just go with that one,
it's not equal to P sub one
and then what we do to actually test,
to actually do the significance test
is we take a sample from the population,
it's going to have a sample size of n,
we need to make sure that we feel good
about making the inference,
we've talked about the
conditions for inference
in previous videos multiple times,
but from this we calculate
the sample proportion
and then from this, we
calculate the P value
and the way that we do the P value,
remember the P value is the probability
of getting a sample proportion
at least this extreme
and if it's below some threshold,
we reject the null hypothesis
and suggest the alternative
and over here the way we do that
is well, we find an associated z value
for that P for that sample proportion
and the way that we calculate it,
we say, okay look, our z is going to be,
how many of the sampling distributions
standard deviations are
we away from the mean
and remember the mean of
the sampling distribution
is going to be the population proportion,
so here we've got this sample statistic,
this sample proportion,
the difference between that
and the assumed proportion,
remember when we do
these significance tests,
we try to figure out the probability
assuming the null hypothesis is true
and so when we see this P sub zero,
this is the assumed proportion
from the null hypothesis,
so that's the difference
between these two,
the sample proportion and
the assumed proportion
and then you'd wanna divide
it by what's often known as
the standard error of the statistic,
which is just the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution
of the sample proportion
and this works out well
for our proportions,
because in proportions, I
can figure out what this is,
this is going to be
equal to the square root
of the assumed population
proportion times one
minus the assumed population
proportion, all of that over n
and then I would use this z statistic
to figure out the P
value and in this case,
I would look at both
tails of the distribution,
because I care about how far I am
either above or below the
assumed population proportion.
Now with means, there's
definitely some similarities here,
you will make a null hypothesis,
maybe you assume the population
mean is equal to mu one
and then there's going to be
an alternative hypothesis,
that maybe your population
mean is not equal to mu one
and you're gonna do something very simple,
you take your population,
you take a sample of size n
and instead of calculating
a sample proportion,
you calculate a sample mean
and actually you can
calculate other things,
like a sample standard deviation,
but now you have an issue,
you say, well ideally I
would use a z statistic
and you could, if you were able to say,
well I could take the difference
between my sample mean
and the assumed mean
in the null hypothesis,
so that would be this right over here,
that's what that zero means,
the assumed mean from the null hypothesis
and I would then divide by the
standard error of the mean,
which is another way of
saying the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution
of the sample mean,
but this is not so easy to figure out,
in order to figure out this,
this is going to be the standard deviation
of the underlying population
divided by the square root of n.
We know what n is going to
be, if we conducted a sample,
but we don't know what
the standard deviation is,
so instead what we do is we estimate this
and so we'll take the sample mean,
we subtract from that the
assumed population mean
from the null hypothesis
and we divide by an estimate of this,
which is going to be our
sample standard deviation
divided by the square root of n,
but because this is an estimate,
we actually get a better result,
instead of saying, hey,
this is an estimate
of our z statistic, we will
call this our t statistic
and as we will see, we will
then look this up in a t table
and this will give us a better
sense of the probability.